je prends une politique de puissance
puissance technologique puissance
économique mais je ne pense pas que
cette puissance
elle passe par le fait de zik de
s'isoler mais je ne pense pas qu'elle
passe par le fait de construire des
lignes maginot
je pense qu'elle passe par le fait
d'avoir des financements qui vont aller
à nos entreprises d'avoir une recherche
publique qui est bien articulée avec une
recherche privée je pense que ça passe
par le fait d'avoir un marché unique
européen sur les technologies de la
troisième révolution industrielle et pas
27 marchés fragmentés
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui de telle
façon que j'ai certaines entreprises qui
sont implantées en france et qui ont
plus de facilité à exporter aux états
unis ou en chine plutôt que dans l'union
européenne parce que nous avons un
marché qui est fragmenté donc moi je
peux vous construire une politique de
puissance dans l'intérêt européen dans
l'intérêt français sans construire des
barricades qu'ils ne seront pas ne
seront pas efficaces
je suis entièrement d'accord sur la
protection intellectuelle bien
évidemment que nous nous sommes fait
avoir sur les questions de protection
intellectuelle par rapport aux chinois
mais on y répond en traitant et en
mettant sur la table le dossier de la
protection intellectuelle pas en
augmentant les droits de douane sur je
ne sais quelle production la question
scandaleuse en effet de
l'extraterritorialité du droit américain
mais c'est pas parce qu'on augmente les
droits de douane que le président trump
à mettre fin à l'extra territorialité du
droit américain c'est parce qu'on
arrivera à répondre sur le même sujet et
aux mêmes et au même niveau donc ceux
qui m'accusent de ça moi je leur retour
l'accusation c'est à dire que je pense
que c'est au contraire en use isolant
qu'on nous affaiblit et c'est d'ailleurs
tout le sujet que nous avons et vous
avez évoqué le fric site
vous avez parfaitement raison mais c'est
tout le débat autour du break cite moi
je ne pense pas que le royaume uni se
soient renforcées en sortant de l'union
européenne je pense qu'il est en train
de passer sous la coupe américaine et
moins comme je suis un patriote un vrai
je préfère partager la souveraineté au
niveau européen plutôt que passer sous
la coupe de
sur américaine
[Musique]